hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
when we're considering the
existentialist movement in
a somewhat narrowed restricted and you
might say even technical range as
albert camus is using the term or
in a broader sense that would include
camus himself
within the existentialist movement and
spectrum
one of the key figures that's going to
come up is
that of the novelist and short story
writer franz
kafka and camus actually devotes
an entire appendix to kafka's works
at the end of the myth of sisyphus
entitled hope and the absurd
in the work of franz kafka
and the title is important
hope is going to be what leads away
from the the orientation toward the
the absurd that camus himself is
advocating in this work and which he
thinks that existentialists in the sense
that he's using the term
are indulging in they're they're moving
away from the kind
of brutal assessments of the world and
human beings
that we should instead remain with and
so the question then
is whether the work of kafka understood
as sort of a proxy for who kafka himself
is
is that work absurd or not
is he absurdist is he existentialist
what should we make of his work and
there's there's two different
seemingly contradictory assessments
built
into this chapter and so on a first or
superficial reading
somebody might get a little bit confused
he says at a certain point i recognize
here a work
that is absurd in its principles so
kafka's work is absurd right
but then a bit later in considering
the castle and the the importance of
that
he is going to uh here we go he says
i shall speak like him and say that his
work is
probably not absurd
so you know you say well one is saying
it definitely is
the other is saying it's probably not
that's not you know the same degree of
certainty
or assertion no he is actually saying
that kafka's work is absurd in one sense
and fails or leaves behind the absurd
by the way it handles the absurd in
another sense and thereby
quits being absurd although it is still
existentialist by the way that kamu
is using this term in a more restricted
meaning and
he's essentially saying that kafka fits
into
those authors that he considered earlier
on in the work
as engaging in philosophical suicide by
making the leap by hoping for something
by turning the absurd
into god and you notice that
his reading here is entirely predicated
on a certain way of arranging
the development and the meaning of
kafka's works
so you know what works does he actually
discuss here
very briefly the metamorphosis actually
not quite so briefly he discusses
you know gregor sampson as the salesman
and why that's important
and his annoyance rather than horror
at finding himself in the situation that
he's in
he devotes quite a lot of space to the
trial and even more so to
the castle he also does mention
in a footnote in the penal colony
so he's not actually considering the
entire range
of kafka's works here and he's treating
the castle
as if it is the essentially the end
point
where kafka's work culminates and all
the other stuff
is before that so there's there's a kind
of developmental
reading going on here that you know i
think even kamu himself
would say this is not the only way to
arrange it
there's no absolute necessity of
framing kafka's work in this way
but it does allow him to engage in the
kind of
project that he wants to do in this
appendix which is to say
look on the one hand this is absurd work
in its principles and we're going to
look at those principles
and the absurdity of it and the artistry
that goes into it that camus himself is
quite attuned to on the other there's
this
wrong or inconsistent treatment
of the absurd that is embodied
within the work the the castle and we'll
get to that in a moment
so he starts out um
by examining the absurdity in kafka's
work
and in the first section he says that
we're going to get
a closed world it it ends
at that point before the the switch to
talking about
the uh the castle and he begins
by saying the whole art of kafka
consists in forcing the reader
to reread so we're always engaged in
kafka's
works when we're reading them properly
when we're not just skimming them
or checking them out so that we can fit
them into some other project when we're
reading them as works
they make us go back and the re-reading
is a duplication
he's going to speak here of ambiguity
and we might actually say that there's a
bit of a play on words here
because there's ambiguities
that kamu is discussing here so even the
word ambiguity
is ambiguous here which ambiguity is it
referring to
so he talks about symbols and
here you know we want to be a little bit
careful don't read in too much
coming from somewhere else about symbols
look at what camus actually says here in
the text
he tells us that a symbol is always in
general and however precise it's
translation
an artist can restore to it only it's
movement there is no word for word
rendering nothing is harder to
understand than a symbolic work
a symbol transcends the one who makes
use of it
so kafka his characters and makes him
say in reality more than he is aware of
expressing so then he says the surest
means of getting hold of it is not to
provoke it
to begin the work without a preconceived
attitude and not to look
for its hidden current so the natural
tendency when we talk about symbols
is we what's going on here what's the
secret thing that only i know
or only my my pals know camus saying
don't do that
just read the kafka and see what happens
in the stories
enter the world of the characters that
has been
been created here and a little bit later
he says
the symbols here it's hard to speak of a
symbol in a tale whose most
obvious quality just happens to be
naturalness
and then a little bit later on he tells
us
that the the worlds are brought together
symbols the symbol brings together two
planes
two worlds of ideas and sensations and a
dictionary of correspondences between
them
and he says this lexicon is the hardest
thing to draw up as a matter of fact
he's speaking uh hyperbolically of a
lexicon here don't use a lexicon
go through it see what's actually
happening and he says awakening to the
two worlds brought face to face is
tantamount to getting on the trail of
their secret relationships what are
these two worlds
these two worlds these two planes are
that of everyday life
and supernatural anxiety he says
then there's an interesting little
footnote here where he says there's
other ways to read this as well
the works of kafka can quite as
legitimately be interpreted in a sense
of social
criticism and then he says it's probable
there's no
real need to choose both interpretations
are good
and this is something that we could
explore at much greater length
in in kamu but we've got two planes
there could be that of everyday life and
then social criticism could everyday
life
supernatural anxiety i think probably
the best
example of this is in the trial
where we discover that the addicts
of all of these places in town
are secretly but actually not secretly
the locus of the law courts that was
that was a symbol that always
gripped me so much about kafka and i
think that
that matches this perfectly there's also
i mentioned ambiguity and camus talks
about
a fundamental ambiguity in which
lies kafkas secret and in the section
where he
uses those terms he outlet he lays out
several of these ambiguities he says
there's perpetual oscillations between
the natural
and the extraordinary so that's one of
the ambiguities going back and forth
is an oscillation the individual and the
universal the tragic
and the everyday the absurd and the
logical
and these are found throughout his work
and give it both its resonance
the way it feels you could say the way
it sounds
and its meaning its meaning lies
in these ambiguities now that's a
paradoxical way to talk
and here he says these are the paradoxes
that must be enumerated
the contradictions that must be now
notice what he says here there isn't the
contradictions that must be explained
away
the contradictions that must be
understood know the contradictions that
must be strengthened
in order to understand the absurd work
so
in order to understand any absurd work
we we have to look at this
but it's even more so important with
with
kafka a little bit earlier
he talks about um the
characters are being dragged off into
the pursuit of problems
they never formulate and this fits in
well with the next thing
that he points out as well about
um consistency and he brings up a kind
of funny
joke which we'll get into in a moment he
says if kafka wants to express the
absurd
he will make use of consistency and this
is this is something that i think has
been
trivialized in in many ways um
you know people try to imitate kafka but
they don't always
pull it off some people do but they
don't always pull it off
because following out the logic
kafka's characters you know follow along
paths that they have not themselves made
that's part of their confrontation with
the absurd world the world
also of others who seem to inhabit this
better than them but may not
may fall into the abyss at any moment
and you're constantly finding out in
kafka's
world as one of his characters that some
sort of decision was made
that basically undid what you were doing
well in advance of it and without even
really caring about it
so you know you'll fill out the
paperwork and then find out oh there was
another form that you should have
gotten and this has to be notarized and
oh it's
you know too late for that now that's
just one example now
he he's got this great passage here he
says
you know the story of the crazy man who
is fishing in a bathtub
a doctor with ideas as to psychiatric
treatments asked him
if they were biting if the fish are
biting in the bathtub and
to which he received the harsh reply of
course not you fool this is a bathtub
and he says it can be grasped quite
clearly to what a degree the absurd
effect is linked
to an excess of logic
an excess of logic too much logic too
much logic in the wrong place perhaps
and he says kafka's world is in truth an
indescribable universe
in which man allows himself the
tormenting luxury of fishing in a
bathtub
knowing nothing will come of it so this
again is pointing towards kafka's works
as
essentially being absurd
but only up to a certain point because
now we bring in
the trial and its relationship to the
castle
in the next section in the appendix
camus tells us
that this world is not as closed as it
seems
in this universe devoid of progress
kafka is going to introduce hope in a
strange
form so it's not straightforward hope
the characters do hope for things right
but then their hopes are
disappointed but there's hope on a
secondary
level we can say almost you could call
it meta hope
hope in the face of the absurd hope
through
the absurd and this is what kamu is
criticizing
in kafka's works and also rejecting for
for himself so he tells us that
here we go the trial propounds a problem
which the castle to a certain degree
solves the first describes according to
a quasi-scientific method and without
concluding
the second to a certain degree explains
the trial diagnosis
the castle imagines a treatment but the
remedy
proposed here does not cure
so it's not so simple as well i you know
came up with the
key ideas and hid an impasse and then
the next book
deals with that and solves solves the
problem the way we might imagine you
know like a science fiction
series which um you know raises a new
new existential threat an existential in
the sense of like can destroy you but it
could also be existential in the sense
of meaning
uh brought about by some new alien race
that was even bigger and badder than the
the previous one
and then in the next book you you take
care of them
no this isn't like that it's it's
arranged in a different way
so he goes on and he says
it brings the malady back into normal
life it helps to accept it
and this is this is what kamu has the
fundamental problem with
so he'll talk about the deification of
the absurd
he'll talk about hope and the leap
and you know these are the terms that as
i mentioned uh were
worked out by him in terms of the other
existentialists and he's going to bring
up kierkegaard
here chester jasper's all these people
he's brought up
before and he's saying that kafka
in the castle is allowing himself to be
drawn down that path
so you know he he summarizes what's
going on in the castle he says
a few works are more rigorous in their
development kay
is named land surveyor to the castle he
arrives in the village and what we find
is that it's impossible to communicate
with the castle so he can't do his job
and he he becomes obsessed with this
idea of gaining access
to the castle a lot of people have
interpreted this well the castle is god
the castle is the kingdom of heaven
the castle is is this and that right
some sort of reconciliation
where all of our hopes and dreams can be
pinned on and it's going to make
everything
right and he tries you know trick after
trick after trick
he says those inspired automatic kafka's
characters provide us with a precise
image of what we would be if we were
deprived of our distractions
and utterly consigned to the
humiliations of the divine and he says
in the castle that surrender to the
everyday becomes
an ethic so we see this invocation right
of
again two planes everyday life the
situations that we're in in which we act
and then this supernatural anxiety this
wish to have things resolved
to figure out once and for all what the
whole point of it
is and he you know he goes through
trying to
go through this intermediary this
intermediary
moving towards the barnabas sisters
which seems to be going in the wrong
direction
but actually you know fits into the
entire theory
he says that the path pursued by kafka's
hero
from frida to the barnabas sisters is
the very one that leads from trusting
love to the
deification of the absurd here again
kafka's thought runs parallel to
kierkegaard
right it's not surprising the barnabas
story is placed at the end of the work
and he says the land surveyor's last
attempt is to recapture
god through what negates him to
recognize him not according to our
categories of goodness and beauty
but behind the empty and hideous aspects
of this indifference his injustice his
hatred the stranger who asked the castle
to adopt
him uh is at the end of his voyage a
little more exiled because this time
he is unfaithful to himself forsaking
morality logic and intellectual truths
in order to try to enter the desert of
divine grace
and here camus is going to say this is
embracing the absurd but in the wrong
way
how so through hope and he says the word
hope is not ridiculous
the more tragic the condition the firmer
and more aggressive that hope becomes
the more truly absurd the trial is the
more moving
and illegitimate notice that term
illegitimate
the impassioned leap of the castle seems
and he says we're in a pure
we find again in a pure state the
paradox of existential thought as it is
expressed
by kierkegaard and you know he goes on
and says
one has to have written the trial to
undertake the castle
we could also say similarly with
kierkegaard
as kierkegaard tells us in fear and
trembling you can't be the knight of
faith
without having gone through infinite
resignation
an infinite resignation is more like
what camus
is uh advocating here in the myth of
sisyphus
right so we've got this
this this leap going on we don't have to
go
uh further with this i i think other
than to say that
what what do kafka kicker garden chest
off
or as he says those in short of
existentialist novelists and
philosophers completely oriented towards
the absurd and its consequences
what makes them do this hope you know
path he says they embrace the god that
consumes them
it's through humility that hope enters
in
and uh camus says no no that's not the
route that an absurdist as opposed to an
existentialist ought to be taking
so he thinks he talks here about
infidelity
and he says that the absurd work can
lead to
an infidelity that he himself camus
wants to avoid and that is what is going
on
in the castle so you know what do we
have with kafka we have a
a writer and his work the body
expressing his stuff that is
definitely worth reading definitely
worth checking out
absurd in its principles absurd actually
in
much of the literature that composes it
just not absurd
in this one particular work that camus
chooses to make
central as kafka's endpoint the
the castle and i suppose you know you
could say
why not why shouldn't that work be the
the end point the last thing i want to
bring up here is he talks about
nobility and universality and here
as we're reading this section um this is
towards the the end he says
um there we go
you see what tradition of thought
kafka's work takes its place
and then he says i'll say his work is
probably absurd but that should not
deter
us from seeing its nobility and
universality
it's tempting to blur those together oh
this is great you know camus is saying
that you know kafka's work is still good
and we have to consider what he means
here by these two terms
it's precisely because it's universal
camus thinks that it cannot remain
absurd
he tells us his work is universal a
really
absurd work is not universal to the
extent to which it represents the
emotionally moving face of man fleeing
humanity
deriving from his contradictions reasons
for believing reasons for hoping from
his fecund despairs
calling life is terrifying
apprenticeship in death it is universal
because its inspiration is religious
so camus is not saying that this
universality is a good thing here he's
saying that's actually
one of its its problems and when we read
you know it's a common place to say oh
you know any one of us could be gregor
samhsa yeah any one of us could be
gregor samsa
that doesn't make him the proverbial
every man right
likewise you know he doesn't name his
his characters
he's just got you know k and joseph k
um they're supposed to be a stand-in for
any one of us
yes and no you know this universality is
a straying away
from the absurd and and he also talks
about nobility and this is something
really quite interesting about camus
he believes that within the absurd
existence that we have a world that
you know doesn't map on to our own
desires and
rationality this divorce between us that
we call the absurd this triadic relation
that it's still possible for human
beings to have nobility it's not
however by being a universal
it is by you know resisting
by rebelling by continually going on
by lingering in the absurd and refusing
to
make the leap that would somehow make it
all make sense refusing to hope
and you notice that he brings in another
another thinker here
he tells us that
here we go this particular view will be
better understood if i say the truly
hopeless thought
just happens to be defined by the
opposite criteria
and that the tragic work might be the
work that after all
future hope is exiled describes the life
of a happy man
happiness and nobility are also
connected here he says the more exciting
life is the more
absurd is the idea of losing it this is
perhaps the secret of the proud aridity
felt in nietzsche's work in this
connection
nietzsche appears to be the only artist
to have derived the extreme consequences
of an aesthetic of the absurd
right so why bring in nietzsche at that
point because camus
is saying at least on this point i mean
there's plenty of other points where i
don't agree with him
nietzsche and i are in agreement and
kafka is over there with chest off and
kierkegaard and these other
essentially religious existentialist
thinkers
so he goes on and he says one other
thing about nobility
he says if nostalgia is the mark of the
human perhaps no one has given such
flesh
and volume to these phantoms of regret
as kafka has
but at the same time will be sensed what
exceptional nobility
the absurd work calls for which is
perhaps
not found here in kafka's work
the nobility that kamu is
you know if there's anything really
positive
in camus ethics being worked out here
it's this concept of
nobility elsewhere he talks about
decency and some other values that he
thinks are possible to have
kafka's works ultimately don't have that
for kamu so this is a very interesting
assessment coming at the end of his work
that
ties together a number of threads that
have been running
throughout it and shows you what camus
is making
of this very important existentialist
author
you